[Musique]
salut je m'appelle Suzie Wallis je veux
résoudre l'insoluble je veux apporter
une résolution au mystère les plus
inextricable pourquoi tu souris je ne
sais pas c'est mon expression habituelle
je vous écoute Sophie
[Musique]
quand le monde est rempli de haine c'est
le moment
moment
j'ai hâte
ça n'a pas d'importance si vous avez
cinq suspects ou 500 plus souvent que
vous ne le pensez le coupable se trouve
juste sous votre nez
[Musique]
je m'appelle Suzy
la véritable Nancy
[Musique]
racontez-nous toute votre enquête
je me souviens avoir appris l'existence
des héros à l'école je n'aurais jamais
pensé rencontrer l'un d'eux j'ai eu des
frissons vous aussi non j'ai eu un tas
de frissons
et toutes les autres personnes dans le
monde porte des masques pas toi ne
change jamais d'accord
je crois que je me suis trompé sur toi
mais bon même si tu es une vraie héroïne
tu as toujours pas de vie sociale
je te promets de ne parler à personne de
ce que j'ai trouvé ici je sais pas de
quoi tu parles mais sors de chez moi le
jour où il a disparu
[Musique]
la vie prend parfois des tournures
inattendues
vous me suivez ils ont trouvé plus de
traces d'ADN
vous pouvez être le meilleur criminel du
monde mais vous n'échapperez pas à la
science
[Musique]
une nouvelle tragédie frappe la vie même
les plans les plus parfaits ne
fonctionnent pas toujours
[Musique]
semaine que mes gars te suivent
parce que finalement une solution se
présentera